pedro sánchez acaba de anunciar la
convocatoria con carácter urgente para
mañana por la mañana de un consejo de
ministros extraordinario con el objetivo
de decretar el estado de alarma aquí en
la comunidad de madrid' este anuncio se
enmarca en el contexto en el que esta
misma mañana hemos conocido la sentencia
del tribunal superior de justicia de
madrid que tumbaba el confinamiento
perimetral el cierre perimetral de la
capital y de otras nueve ciudades
también de aquí de la comunidad de
madrid' que se encontraban cerradas
desde el pasado viernes 2 de octubre el
tribunal en su sentencia argumenta que
estas medidas están basadas en una orden
ministerial una legislación que no tiene
suficiente rango como para que se
traduzca en una limitación de las
libertades individuales y de los
derechos fundamentales de los ciudadanos
es por esto que el gobierno de españa'
moviliza ahora el instrumento del estado
de alarma como ya lo hizo entre el mes
de marzo y el mes de junio eso sí no nos
situaríamos ahora en el mismo escenario
no estaríamos hablando de un
confinamiento domiciliario y a nivel
geográfico esta medida se limitaría a la
comunidad de madrid' esto si lo que el
gobierno puede hacer es
decretar el estado de alarma por una
duración máxima de 15 días una potencial
prórroga le pediría que esta medida
fuera sometida al congreso de los
diputados donde debería obtener una
mayoría absoluta en la cámara